[Musique]
et
franck ferrand bonjour bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui j'ai donc le plaisir de
recevoir un historien un auteur un
chroniqueur on peut le lire dans la
presse on peut l'écouter à la radio
radio classique
on peut le voir à la télévision et
aujourd'hui nous fait le plaisir d'être
sur le plateau tv 78 pour 2,2 livre deux
ouvrages tout récent donc transférant
bonjour comment ça va bonjour eric
bonjour a tous besoin
je revis d'autres avec pour ça fait
maintenant un nombre de livres que nous
nous voyons
et oui ça fait la quatrième fois donc
merci vous cette fidélité
j'en suis très touché la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus c'était au théâtre
montansier à versailles et vous faisiez
votre émission de radio en direct et en
public
bien sûr et vous sortiez le premier
franck ferrand raconte alors il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui vous sortez le
deuxième vingt portraits vins d'estaing
et comme par hasard
comme de par hasard on retrouve
versailles avoue l'amoureux de cette
ville qui est votre ville de coeur je
crois on retrouve le grand colbert on
retrouve le mariage de louis 16ème et
antoinette on retrouve le ce la
signature du traité de versailles en 19
on retrouve plein de choses qui nous qui
sont passés à versailles
voilà on est tous les chemins mènent à
rome mais tous les histoires versailles
est un peu notre notre boussole dans
l'histoire de france c'est comme ça en
tout cas que moi je là je le perçois
cette ville laissée et son chef
oui c'est incontournable d'accord donc
ça c'est à lire c'est très fluide très
facile alliés sont des événements qu'on
a oublié ou pas mais qui sont bon de se
remémorer
alors maintenant moi j'attaque un autre
morceau vous voulez dire un truc franck
un an je voulais juste vous dire que
c'est tous les textes qui sont un texte
initial combourg bord historia nourrit
de dire france et le choeur de mons
devons savoir faire c'est à dire que
j'aime en août
tant de mots plonge les électeurs où les
auditeurs dans une atmosphère dans une
aventure dans une histoire et embarque
une certaine manière et et pour 13 de
destin un moyen des ambassades et des
moyens de plongée vite vite fait d'en au
coeur du sujet au coeur du passé voilà
alors là c'est moi un mot rapide c'est
le sait le comment dire le la longueur
du roman ce n'est pas un roman ça
s'appelle l'année jones était un conte
politique c'est paru chez plon
il ya très peu de temps vous l'avez
écrit quand ce livre c'est un livre que
j'ai écrit pendant le premier conflit
mans celui auquel on croyait encore vous
savez dans le temps les beaux jours de
2020 nous étions douze fois c'est chez
nous et moi j'avais commencé à écrire un
livre sur les frères corneille un vrai
rebond et parfois que derrière le grand
corneille se cachait le petit thomas en
frais au xviie siècle a eu beaucoup plus
de succès que corneille lui-même lé
corps on a eu et je voulais raconter
l'histoire de ces deux frères
il y avait d'ailleurs épousé les deux
soeurs les soeurs lempérière et raconter
comment ces deux ménages avaient passées
ensemble leurs vies dans un univers qui
était d'abord et avant tout le monde du
théâtre
bien sûr nous utilisons le l'occasion
pour moi revenir sur cette fameuse
polémique qui par ailleurs m'attend
coûté mai et qui est en train de
ressurgir à la faveur de des projets de
santé au nizan de molière la fameuse la
fameuse affaire corneille molière bref
j'étais partie de l'écriture et au
moment du confinement je me suis mis à
mon ordinateur j'avais toute la
documentation réunie depuis des années
maintenant sur scène taylor chorney
était prêt
mon éditeur thierry billard ighil à
l'époque chez plon me dit écoute là
maintenant tu vas pouvoir dit m tu vas
pas pouvoir me dire que tu n'as pas le
temps que tu es pris les discours est ma
mère est rien et je me suis dit oui je
vais écrire sauf qu'en écrivant je suis
rendu compte que j'avais surtout envie
de parler d'actualité
d'accord il me moquer tellement grave ce
que nous traversons est tellement
terrible qu'il était un cri soir vous se
cacher derrière l'histoire et d'aller se
préoccuper du 17e siècle d'accord donc
là vous avez affronté le présent par don
à la parole vous avez à fonder le
présent de face et de plein fouet et
d'ailleurs vous dites souvent on vous
sollicite bien évidemment en tant
qu'historien et on a l'impression que
vous aimeriez d'ailleurs c'est fait
donnez votre avis de citoyen finalement
avec votre votre background d'historiens
évidemment donc on va peut-être quand
même raconté de quoi ça parle
alors cette jeanne pour répondre à cette
question c'est le sait le centre de la
sphère savez moi j'ai fait des études de
sciences politiques d'abord et avant
tout un passionné par la vie politique
française depuis 40 ans je pense qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup de tribunes ou de
débat que j'ai manqué depuis 40 ans j'ai
fait beaucoup de droit public et
d'économie politique je suis passionné
par toutes ces questions en france et à
l'étranger
à chaque fois que je suis invité sur un
plateau de radio enfin dans un studio de
radio sur un plateau de télé on traiter
roges les personnes autour de moi sur le
dernier décret ministériel sur sur une
crise sociale sur des événements des
troubles divers et variés et moi
systématiquement sur tourner pour moi au
dernier moment et on dit et alors
c'était comment handicap
cet équipement du temps de saint louis
je vous ai dit tu passes en 75 une viac
littéralement j'y bosse à de terribles
et donc mes envies que
mes chers confrères d'abord et avant
tout comprennent que je pouvais aussi
avocate parler de politique d'actualité
et je crois que ça il n'en compte plus
que maintenant il ne cesse de me
sollicitations là vous êtes sollicité de
tous les médias ok donc là dedans alors
on va aller un petit peu vite parce
qu'on n'a que treize minutes je vous le
rappelle malheureusement ne peut pas
excuser moi papa donc très bien dormi
réponse merci donc cette fameuse jeanne
donc ce livre vous le vous l'écrivez
enfin c'est une jeune chargé de mission
du président actuel on est en 2022 qui
m'écrit c'est le successeur du président
macron puisque les machines à la fin de
2021 devant la catastrophe le président
mccourt est obligé de démissionner j'ai
donc son successeur le var en l1 très
gênante
oui par l'intermédiaire d'une jeune
chargé de mission qui est la narratrice
alors vous placer l'histoire en 2020
vous la fait raconter l'histoire en 2070
cette fameuse jeanne elle arrive de
nouvelle calédonie elle a été prise de
cécité à 12 ans et elle arrive un peu
comme une voie salvatrice
j'ai l'impression que vous en ce
personnage c'est un mélange de de jeanne
d'arc et de jeanne antide tour ict est
une sainte un peu moins connus est ce
que c'est ça l'idée alors jeanne antide
touré a donné son prénom à mon héroïne
en otage un appel lui a donné toute son
histoire puisque vous avez remarqué
évidemment que je me suis amusé c'était
le confinement je vous dis fallait bien
s'amuser un peu noyés et je me suis
amusé à transposer it la saga de jeanne
d'arc du 15e siècle dont le 21e siècle
est en fait épisode par épisode
ma petite calédonienne va vivre ce que
la barre oise jeanne avait vécu dans les
ier 14 20 et 30
elle dans le métro ce type d'actes mans
l'histoire de jeanne d'arc de sueur mais
à notre époque et c'est incroyable
jeanne d'arc d'aujourd'hui de rencontrer
un certain nombre d'interlocuteurs dans
la société actuelle française
voilà donc vous évoquez un nombre
incalculable de deux sujets politiques
donc les médias tiens au hasard vous
reprochez aux médias de nous mettre fin
notamment les médias d'information
continue de
nous mettre en état d'hypnose ils en
prennent pour leur grade
quel intérêt de nous hypnotiser de nous
rendre ne votre avis je pense qu'il n'y
a pas d'intérêt particulier l'intérêt
c'est de faire de l'audience dsk et le
dites moi et c'est de gagner chaque
chaque jour chez moi en audience
c'est aussi simple c'est tout d'accord
je comprend alors pourquoi l'avoir fait
venir venir de nouvelle calédonie de si
loin pourquoi est ce qu'elle est avec
elle c'est un message supplémentaire
elle vient de nouvelle calédonie parce
que c'est la transposition démarche de
lorraine dans venait jeanne d'arc et
pour vous avoir fait un film parce que
les les grands actionnaires de de
l'histoire et de la légende sont souvent
aveugle on dit kommer était aveugle
n'est ce pas quelle chance que ma jeanne
antide étant aveugle bénéficie en
quelque sorte d'une sensibilité
particulière lui conférer une certaine
certain nombre d'accords bon alors vous
êtes plutôt optimiste ou pessimiste
magie l'impression que j'avais envie de
dire pessimiste il faut que qu'est ce
que vous nous dites là maintenant à part
lisez mon livre je pense que le sujet
n'est pas d'être optimiste ou pessimiste
le reportage très positif
j'espère lui une possible c'est le
message de jeanne en disant que c'est
vrai que notre civilisation et sur le
bâtiment en pleine décadence
mais tout n'est pas tout à fait ce que
vient dire cette jeanne homogène
président élu qui est un peu l'équipe
pont du charles vii
aujourd'hui ce qu'elle vient de dire
c'est qu'en pointe il est encore
peut-être possible de faire quelque
chose et que si le feu d'artifice a déjà
été tiré et qu'il est derrière nous on
doit en revanche pouvoir encore donner
un bouquet final est que la ce bouquet à
l'occidentale
c'est la france qui est la mieux placée
pour le tirer aujourd'hui à condition
quelques feuilles et qu'elle s'en donne
les moyens bien sûr et vous avez faut
j'ai l'impression que vous donnez comme
planche de salut et de deux éléments à
mettre bien
un en-avant et à prioriser se sont
l'éducation et la culture
si vous étiez prise volant on est
d'accord tout passe par le mans tout
commence par là la culture c'est l'alpha
et l'oméga de la politique et
l'éducation
c'est ce qui permet de constituer une
société digne de ce nom est une société
qui soit véritablement démocratique et
adultes et donc je pense que le grand
grand grand tort que nous avons eues
depuis bien longtemps maintenant depuis
presque un demi-siècle
c'est de laisser les pédagogistes
prendre l'éducation nationale en otage
et détruire le grand bagage de
transmission qui avait fait la force et
la grandeur de notre civilisation qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire du coup faut tout
reprendre à zéro de ce point de vue ça
c'est un travail de longue haleine
et puis il faut surtout essayer de
mettre systématiquement en avant
là comment pourrait-on dire ça ce que
j'appelle le coeur dans le ligne à la
caravane le rsa voilà pas le coeur océan
ce sentiment du terme pas le coeur au
centre générosité quoique et le coeur
aussi
courage il faut oser affronter les
choses en face
il faut se retrousser les manches et se
mettre à l'ouvragé envie de faire de la
politique
j'aurais très envie mais c'est déjà le
cas de jouer sur ce livre fait partie de
près avec les hommes politiques de décès
qui de d'essayer justement lénine leur
donner un peu de courage le redonner un
peu d'allant et et et les aider dans une
tâche qui est extrêmement difficile
à titre personnel non je ne veux pas
faire de politique je pense d'ailleurs
je ne me rappelais 1 aurait pas de
compétence
j'aurais peut-être les compétences pour
conquérir le pouvoir je ne suis pas
persuadé que j'aurais les compétences
qui me permet l'exercice à venir non
débat public et livré mon opinion vous
avez remarqué que maintenant ça y est ça
y est et vannes sont ouvertes au caire
extra bah écoute et merci beaucoup
corneille on peut quand même l'espérer
ou pas bah écoutez si si un jour j'ai
2dans ensi j'espère qu'il ne faudra pas
un nouveau confinement complet pour me
plaire d'internés oui mais bon j'espère
effectivement un jour ce livre on y
verra le ral chaud parce qu'on retient
concoeur très bien bah non merci franck
ferrand merci alors on ferait tant on
sait vous nous avez livré votre coeur
voilà dans tous les sens du terme
à très vite et je vous dis au revoir
olé olé coeur voilà merci à bientôt
il